you
the body's smallest adversaries are
medicines biggest challenge it's this
fascinating sort of mystery with lives
in the balance
people need to protect their children
from this kind of crippling disease a
relentless pursuit by Nobel Prize
laureates every kind of medical disease
we don't know the cause of is now being
thoroughly investigated challenging old
ways of thinking and sometimes putting
careers at risk I told the department
chair that if it didn't work out I
probably would go into real estate can
we decipher their secrets and one day
declare victory in the war against
microbes
funding is provided by the Astra Zeneca
noble medicine initiative polio has been
sort of the driver in my life I consider
what I can't do along with what I can do
and just about every decision I make
franciene Falk Allen has lived almost
her entire life with the crippling
effects of an infectious disease polio
in 1951 when she was just three years
old she contracted the disease that for
many children proved fatal I was playing
at the neighbor's house I couldn't get
up off the floor and the mother of my
friends called my mother and said
Francine can't get up a highly
contagious virus was attacking nerve
cells in Francine's body making it
impossible for her to move her legs the
next thing that I remember clearly was
being hospitalized for the quarantine
period that was the first two weeks in
1951 Francine was one of 28 thousand
Americans diagnosed with polio by the
following year the number more than
doubled the three year old Los Angeles
girl was forced into a heartbreaking
sequence of hospitalizations and
treatments my recollection is that my
parents came to visit me once and I
reached out mommy picked me up you know
and she said I can't I can't touch you
and I was crying and my mother could
barely keep from crying
at first Francine's prognosis was poor
the doctors told my mother that I was
never going to walk again I'd be in a
wheelchair the rest of my life but they
decided that I was a candidate for
therapy and so they gradually taught me
to walk again with the Kinney Stix today
there are nearly half a million polio
survivors like Francine in the United
States but remarkably that number will
likely dwindle to zero in a matter of
decades that's because a vaccine has
almost completely eradicated the disease
but that vaccine would not have been
possible without the work of generations
of scientists who dared to defy
conventional wisdom people like the 17th
century Dutch amateur scientist Anton
van Leeuwenhoek he had a very primitive
microscope by our standards in fact if
you saw it you wouldn't even recognize
it
he said wonderful little animals
swimming under my microscope people
didn't know the details of their anatomy
and physiology but they were quite sure
they were alive and produced little
offspring like themselves he had
discovered a whole new class of
organisms bacteria but it was far from
certain whether these tiny swimmers
could actually harm us for many people
it was difficult to imagine how these
tiny little organisms that you couldn't
even see with the naked eye how could
they cause a terrible disease like
cholera or bubonic plague
it would take another 200 years before a
German bacteriologist Robert Koch
answered that question in 1876 Robert
Koch is a key figure some might even say
the key figure in the development of
germ theory of disease he isolated the
organism that caused cholera he isolated
the organism that caused tuberculosis
when Cole announced that he had
discovered the causative agent of
tuberculosis it was a media storm Kaka
believed he could cure the disease with
a preparation made from laboratory
cultures of tuberculosis bacteria he
called it tuberculous people flocked to
him for treatment with tuberculous and
we're very much disappointed he thought
he had developed a cure but he had
jumped the gun this was known as the
tuberculin fiasco and it very much
damaged his reputation but Cocker
struggled with more than just as failure
to cure tuberculosis he also met
continued resistance to the novel idea
that a tiny microbe can cause dreaded
diseases like TB and cholera in fact
there was a famous scientist named Max
von paedon cough who publicly swallowed
a solution of the cholera bacillus to
prove that the disease was not caused by
this bacillus now he must have been
pretty lucky because he actually did not
get the disease but Cooke was not alone
the great French scientist Louis Pasteur
also did experiments that helped prove
that microorganisms cause disease
he became revered for creating vaccines
against rabies and anthrax but he died
in 1895 six years before the first Nobel
Prize an award that Cook would receive
in 1905 for his own enormous
contributions to microbiology
with the idea that microbes cause
disease known as the germ theory now
establish beyond a doubt scientists
began to zero in on ways to attack
microorganisms to either cure or prevent
disease it's easy enough to kill
microbes in the test tube but the great
challenge is to find a drug that is safe
and effective
in a human being one of the first to
rise to this challenge was Nobel Prize
laureate Paul Ehrlich who in 1910
announced that the drug Solverson could
effectively combat syphilis in 1939
Gerhardt democ was awarded a Nobel Prize
for discovering that sulfa drugs could
protect mice and rabbits against some
bacterial infections but it was only
because of a misfortune at home that he
learned the drugs could also work in
humans his own daughter developed the
very bad streptococcal infection from a
wound and in desperation because often
these infections were fatal he tried
this drug on her even though it had only
been tried on mice and she survived but
the greatest anti bacterial discovery of
them all was also the luckiest Alexander
Fleming said that if he had been more
tidy and careful he might never have
discovered anything Fleming was working
with a Staphylococcus bacterium when he
went on vacation leaving dirty petri
dishes on the sink if you have
absolutely perfect technique you would
not have mold on your petri dishes where
you're trying to grow bacteria but
Fleming did and he noticed that in the
area close to the mold there were no
colonies of Staphylococcus growing and
he postulated that maybe this mold was
preventing the growth of the
staphylococci or killing them Fleming
had accidentally discovered penicillin
the first true antibiotic but a viable
drug made from the penicillin mold would
only come ten years later it was Howard
Florey and Ernst chain who isolated pure
penicillin
and in 1945 all three scientists Fleming
chain and Florrie received the Nobel
Prize the discovery of penicillin is
true highlight in the history of the
battle against infectious disease
penicillin opened the door to the great
Golden Age of antibiotics by embracing
the germ theory scientists had developed
countless new vaccines and treatments
yet many killer diseases stubbornly
eluded the grasp of microbiologists one
of them was polio which was caused not
by a bacterium but by a foe that was
much smaller and more difficult to
detect a virus karl landsteiner was the
first to isolate the polio virus but
until scientists could figure out how to
reproduce that virus in large numbers
progress towards making a vaccine would
be stymied the top polio scientists were
convinced that the virus could grow only
in nerve tissue the target of its
crippling attack polio virus until the
1940s could only be produced in the
brains and nervous systems of monkeys
they simply didn't know how else it
could be grown but virus from a monkey
brain was not safe for a human vaccine
and even if it were no one knew how to
make huge quantities of it some of the
greatest minds in biology
focused on the problem but the
breakthrough came from a most unexpected
person John Enders was one of the most
remarkable researchers of the 20th
century scion of a wealthy Boston
banking family John Enders knocked
around for several years before choosing
to pursue a career in research and
believe me until the late 1940s he had
made no splash in the medical community
at Boston Children's Hospital Enders
allied himself with two young
researchers Tom Weller and Fred Robbins
they focused on childhood diseases like
chickenpox by intuition they decided
that while they were testing their
chickenpox they would also take some
polio virus
that they had stored and they would put
it into a medium not with monkey brain
tissue but with tissue from other parts
of the body's non nervous tissue it
defied all the conventional wisdom about
polio but Enders had noticed that a lot
of the virus could be found not just in
nerve cells but also in the gut of polio
victims so Enders thought to himself
jeez if poliovirus goes through the nose
into the brain into the central nervous
system
what is so much of it doing in the
digestive tract the hunch was correct
polio virus could be grown in vitro in a
test tube away from monkeys they
published their startling report in 1949
once John Enders and his colleagues
published their findings It was as if a
cannon went off in polio research Jonas
Salk took one look at this paper and
said my god
here is the missing link what I can do
now is set up a laboratory that can
produce safe poliovirus
in gallons in tubs and once that
happened they knew they were on the road
to a vaccine that road ended in 1954
with the largest public health
experiment in American history more than
a million children took part in trials
for the sock polio vaccine it took a
full year to analyze the data but in
1955 the word came down that the vaccine
was safe and potent and effective it was
like a war had ended the war against
polio Albert Saban's oral polio vaccine
followed soon on the heels of socks
injectable version for their life-saving
vaccines Salk and Sabin earned the
adulation of the world but the Nobel
Committee honored the dramatic
breakthrough of Ender's Weller and
Robbins that made the vaccines possible
the most important building block had
been laid by John Enders he had the
Moxie to challenge the most important
polio researchers on the most important
single polio research question the polio
vaccine came too late for Francine Allen
but it has prevented untold thousands of
American children from suffering the way
she did the only disease we've ever
eradicated from the face of the earth is
smallpox we are this close to doing it
to polio and I believe we will certainly
within the next four or five years and
after that the sky's the limit but the
battle against infectious diseases is
always challenging especially when
scientists don't even realize they're
fighting a microbe well the initial
discovery I first found the bacteria by
accident I suppose in the 1980s Robin
Warren was working in a laboratory in
Western Australia analyzing tissue
samples from biopsies I worked in the
laboratory not with the patient so I
just saw bits of patients one day he
noticed something odd I found a section
of stomach which had quite severe
gastritis and I noticed that there was a
funny-looking blue line on the surface
of the mucosa to observe it more clearly
Warren put it under a high-powered
microscope and with that it looked like
a lot of bacteria on the surface of the
stomach it was a shocking thing to find
everybody knew bacteria didn't grow in
the stomach that's what we were taught
according to all the medical literature
what Warren was seeing couldn't possibly
exist but he was sure it did I was
seeing them because they were they're
like I'm seeing you in front of me I
know I know you're there and if if that
fellow over there tries to tell me
you're not there I said well alright if
you think that let's okay but I know
you're there
for a time Warren's observation was
nothing more than a curiosity that's
about as far as I could go as a
pathologist but with Barry's help we
went a lot further of course Barry is
Barry Marshall at the time he was a
young physician and training in search
of an interesting research project and I
spoke to my boss I said is there a
research project in the gastroenterology
department he said well you know that
pathologists Robin Warren and Robin was
her a bit of a recluse he lived down in
the basement of Royal Perth Hospital so
I went down there and what he showed me
was a collection of about 20 patients
who had stomach tissue biopsies probably
taken to check for cancer or something
and on these pieces of tissue you could
see curved bacteria so clearly the poor
old Australian patients at least had
been colonized with some kind of curved
bacteria Marshall and Warren noticed an
extraordinarily high correlation between
the presence of the bacteria and ulcers
but there was one big problem with their
observation everybody knew that ulcers
were caused by spicy foods and alcohol
and stress and things like that so we
were suggesting that ulcers were caused
by bacteria that everybody knew were
there and they were causing ulcers that
everybody knew were caused by other
things despite the microscopic evidence
that the bacteria called Helicobacter
pylori were indeed causing ulcers
Marshall and Warren had a long way to go
before they could persuade the rest of
the world I think if you've got
something totally new you've got to
expect to be able to prove that to
everybody to do that they would have to
follow a series of steps first outlined
by Robert Koch called Koch's postulates
one of them is you have to infect an
experimental animal with the bacteria
and show that the disease develops in
the animal we had no animal for
Helicobacter in those days so I decided
that I was going to have to do it on a
human so that's all very well except the
fact that I was the only human in the
world at that time who knew enough about
the bacteria to judge that it was you
know how risky it was or whatever so I
decided that I needed
that experiment on myself I had an
endoscopy to show that I was completely
normal no bacteria in the stomach no
ulcers or anything and then a month
later I drank a pure culture of the
bacteria actually Barry wouldn't let me
mention the fact that he'd done this to
anybody else because as I said at the
time we were pushing this a little bit
too hard perhaps then a lot of people
thought with the crackers
after about five or six days I started
vomiting each day and feeling unwell I
wasn't sleeping I was breaking out in
the sweat and then on the tenth day we
put the scope down and took some
biopsies and sure enough the bacteria
had invaded the wall my stomach and lots
of white cells exactly what we saw in
also patients he actually got quite sick
and his wife was very angry about it
because he did does her permission until
they're before she was quite horrified
him you did what but she's very nice
however she did insist that I take some
antibiotics after that and all was well
after about two and a half weeks back to
normal by taking this personal risk
Marshall had shown that bacteria could
indeed in fact a healthy stomach and
cause ulcers I felt that was very urgent
to try and prove or disprove these
bacteria as a cause of ulcers because
about 10 percent of the adult population
of the Western world were developing
ulcers at some time in their life so I
could see that if we could cure ulcers
with antibiotics that would be very
important to thousands or you know maybe
millions of people after several years
of rejections Warren and Marshall
succeeded in publishing their research
in the journal The Lancet after we
published our first paper in 1984 Robin
and I went out to dinner with our wives
and I remember Robins wife when said you
know very you two might win the Nobel
Prize for this and Robin thought he said
yeah Wendy reckon we'll do it
and I said 1986 in truth it would take
nearly two more decades but in 2005
Warren and Marshall received the Nobel
Prize for discovering the ulcer causing
bacterium that nobody believed could
survive in the human stomach I think
that the best science very often does
emerge when the results don't fit the
accepted paradigms
it's the surprises it's the unexpected
results in the 1970s stanley prisoner a
neurologist at the university of
california san francisco began the work
that would eventually lead to his nobel
prize he discovered a mysterious new
kind of pathogen neither bacterium nor
virus that seemed to break one of the
most basic rules of biology the catalyst
was the sudden death of a patient from
creutzfeldt-jakob disease a rare brain
disorder I was just beginning my
residency in neurology but in 3 months
this poor woman went from a very lovely
person aged 60 to someone who was mute
unable to walk would just lie in bed and
stare at the ceiling at the time
scientists believed the disease was
caused by an unidentified virus and yet
she didn't seem to have any of the
defense responses that we associate with
viral infections using mouse brains
infected by scrapey an illness similar
to creutzfeldt-jakob disease prisoners
lab set up a series of rigorous tests
they appeared to reveal that the agent
that caused the disease was not a virus
or surprisingly it contained neither RNA
nor DNA one or both of which are found
in every other infectious agent
and when I say infectious what I mean is
that it's self propagating that it
multiplies so nobody was prepared for
something which didn't have RNA or DNA
shocked by his own findings prisoner
continued to search for the RNA or DNA
that would indicate a virus the more
prisoner purified his infectious agent
the clearer it was
that did not contain any more na or DNA
it was a pure protein people did not
believe at the time that a pure protein
could be an infectious agent it became
clear to me that we were dealing with
something which was much different than
a virus a bacterium or a fungus prisoner
called these infectious proteins prions
they are chains of amino acids that fold
into an abnormal shape and can cause
disease but his unconventional theory
was greeted with widespread skepticism
it's a paradigm shift I mean you know
here we've been going along thinking
that microbes are you know bacteria and
viruses and that's what makes you sick
from an infection Stanley was coming up
with this idea that it's really just a
protein and this protein can be
transmitted and it's infectious that was
just something that didn't compute I
think this resistance probably was
pretty good because what it forced me to
do was to keep working keep generating
data I was worried that I was wrong I
was worried that I wasn't gonna have a
job I wasn't gonna have a livelihood I
told the department chair that if it
didn't work out I probably would go into
real estate instead of staying around
UCSF and licking my wounds for the next
25 or 30 years
then at a certain point it became pretty
clear to me that it was very likely that
I was right and that this was really a
major discovery it took more than a
decade but eventually the scientific
community accepted prisoners finding
that prions did indeed cause
creutzfeldt-jakob disease I knew that he
was on to something and it was very
clear to me that he had described the
cause for creutzfeldt-jakob disease but
I didn't think at that time that this
would have broader implications for
neurodegenerative diseases Cruisers
colleague Bruce Miller treats
degenerative diseases of the brain like
Parkinson's Alzheimer's and ALS or Lou
Gehrig's disease these diseases take out
what we call our higher cortical
functions our language our visual
spatial skills and they take away our
ability to sympathize and empathize with
others to behave appropriately they're
slow they're insidious and eventually
are lethal as Stanley prisoners research
progress scientists like Bruce Miller
began to suspect that his breakthrough
might have broader implications with
Stan prisoner described in the early
1980s seems at a mechanistic level to
explain many if not all of these
neurodegenerative conditions I think
it's very likely based upon data from
lots of different laboratories over the
last five years that Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease ALS even
Huntington's disease that all of these
diseases are caused by prions prions may
even help explain what causes a
debilitating brain disease that
scientists are discovering is far more
prevalent than they previously believed
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or CTE
we've known about it since the 1920s we
were familiar with what happened to
boxers they got punch strong or what we
call dementia pugilistica
and I think that was conceptually easy
for us to understand because your are
individuals getting hit in the head
repeatedly that kind of behavior leads
to brain damage
but at a Veterans Affairs hospital just
outside Boston neuro pathologist Ann
McKie has been finding the tell-tale
signs of CTE in the brains of any other
people including those of soldiers and
dozens of former professional athletes
like Chicago Bears safety Dave Duerson
he was a very intelligent man went to
Notre Dame did well in school was a very
successful football player and when he
retired became a very successful
businessman in the Chicago area and then
his life about four years before he died
started to just spiral out of control he
lost his business his marriage dissolved
he complained about headaches which had
persisted since he retired from football
but were becoming increasingly severe
and then one day he shoots himself in
the heart and leaves a text message to
his family that he wants to donate his
brain to the NFL brain bed researchers
were shocked to see that a large number
of due ursins brain cells had died
we were able to see the brain of a 50
year old man which in my business is a
young man with very pronounced
neurodegeneration McKee has also found
evidence that even what we think of as
mild blows to the head from heading a
soccer ball or playing school football
may over time caused the onset of CTE
which then spreads just like an
infection CT is not the result of a
single blow to the head it's most likely
result of multiple blows and what
happens is the the multiple blows
trigger a disease and once the disease
is triggered it doesn't stop the
identity of the infectious agent and CTE
has long been a mystery but it now
appears the culprit may be a Mis folded
protein very much like a prion called
tau this trauma sets up the
transformation of normal tau into a
prion form of tau and then as more and
more of these cow prions are formed they
then aggregate into fibers and the
fibers coalesce can the tangles so it's
really just you know sort of chaos for
the brain it's not just inside these
cells but it's affecting all of their
connections with other neurons the
research is to understand this disease
at the molecular level so we can treat
it so we can figure out a way to reverse
it and stop it
it's a goal that has United researchers
ever since Anton van Leeuwenhoek first
discovered bacteria about 350 years ago
my hope for infectious disease science
is that it keeps unraveling new and
exciting paradigms of disease and then
we keep getting new clues on how to
develop treatments to reduce human
suffering in the future scientists will
have to deal with new and emerging
diseases re-emerging diseases that's why
the battle is never-ending we still have
a lot of work to do with respect to
basic science we need to know much more
about these organisms about their
ableism about their weaknesses some
people think we might totally conquer
infectious disease will it ever happen I
think it's the Holy Grail it's the goal
but it's not I don't think is going to
happen in my lifetime I think the main
moral is to keep your eyes open and not
to ignore something because there's a
known fact
so anything someone says is a non fact I
look at it two or three times
funding is provided by the Astra Zeneca
noble medicine initiative